So from the Trait Theory perspective people have consistent and unique
dispositions for behaving and there are five major dimensions of personality,
openness, conscientiousness, extroversion, agreeableness and nervousness or
neuroticism and recall also that traits lower our threshold for behaving in
particular ways and that these traits exists on a continuum from low on one
side to high on the other. And therefore we can plot any person's personality
on a graph, just as we have here. So here are my scores after taking the big
five personality test. So I was very high in openness to new experiences. I was
medium low on conscientiousness, a little bit closer to the disorganized side.
I was medium high on extroversion. I was high, quite high, on agreeableness and
I was also quite low on nervousness or another way of saying that would be high
on calmness and relaxation. And the nice thing about this personality
questionnaire is you can compare other people too. So Lauren, for instance,
took the same test. And here were her scores. We were very similar on openness
to experience. She was higher on conscientiousness, very high on extroversion,
you might have gotten a sense that she's very extroverted. She's also a very
agreeable, medium high at least. And we're very similar on calmness, neither
one of us gets too nervous and high strung.